the first full transcripts released in
the house impeachment inquiry show the
former US ambassador to Ukraine felt
intimidated when she heard what
president from said about her to
Ukraine's president mr. Trump called the
impeachment probe a brazen assault on
our nation at a rally in Kentucky last
night Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
Nancy we're also hearing a former
associate of Rudy Giuliani may get
involved in the investigation
that's right Lev harness who was
recently arrested on campaign finance
violations will apparently now comply
with a subpoena and testify before
Congress he allegedly helped Rudy
Giuliani get that US ambassador to
Ukraine removed because he believed
allegedly that she was standing in the
way of his business dealings their
deranged hyper-partisan impeachment with
charge at a Kentucky rally president
Trump slammed the impeachment inquiry
Senator Rand Paul joined in we also now
know the name of the whistleblower I say
tonight to the media do your job and
print his name the whistleblowers
identity has not been revealed his or
her lawyer said any member of Congress
who tries to out the whistleblower is a
disgrace in the crowd some Trump
supporters donned t-shirts that said
read the transcript a reference to the
president's July phone call with the
Ukrainian president my phone call was
perfect done mr. Trump insists the call
was perfect but a newly released
testimony former ambassador Murray
Ivanovitch says she felt threatened when
she learned that the president called
her bad news and warned she was going to
go through some things this is someone
who served the country with distinction
for decades it is someone who also is
one of the first witnesses to this
irregular back-channel that the
president established with Rudy Giuliani
Ivanovitch also told lawmakers she was
warned by Ukrainian officials last
winter to watch her back because the
president's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani was planning to do things
including to her she
fired finally Giuliani apparently viewed
ambassador Jovanovic as an impediment to
his efforts to get Ukraine to
investigate president Trump's potential
rival Joe Biden reach the sphere I agree
that the president has the ability to
name who he wants more deposition
transcripts are being released today on
the docket Kurt Volker the former
special envoy to Ukraine and the
ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sandlin two people who were
instrumental in creating that back
channel to the Ukrainians urging them to
open the investigations that the
president was interested in Toni Nancy
as we get closer to public impeachment
hearings our team there in Washington is
learning more about the Republicans
political strategy what more can you
tell us that's right well these public
hearings are viewed by both sides as so
crucial in shaping American opinion and
so Republicans CBS News has learned are
considering putting Jim Jordan
temporarily on the House Intelligence
Committee he has been one of the
president's fiercest defenders he has
been in all of these depositions he's
not on the Intel committee but he may be
assigned there temporarily so he can
continue to make that case over the next
few weeks as we move into public
hearings all right Nancy thank you very
much